anthony cabaza es una excepción en
california tierra demócrata este hijo de
emigrantes y padre de tres no tiene
miedo a mostrar su apoyo a los
republicanos pese a que su defensa de
donald trump le ha costado relaciones e
incluso amenazas de muerte
verdaderamente parece ser que le importa
mucho este país y toda la gente que está
aquí no no solamente a la gente
americana blanca o afroamericanos el
importante la gente porque sus pólizas
ayudan a toda la gente el feudo de los
demócratas es también el estado natal de
la candidata a la vicepresidencia y
senadora por california kamala harris la
comunidad latina forma la cuarta parte
del electorado con 79 millones de
votantes elegibles y es un fuerte apoyo
para los progresistas azules como este
grupo de mujeres latinas que rechazan la
retórica divisiva y anti migración de
trump y ven en el candidato demócrata a
la casa blanca una posibilidad de cambio
para mí su padre es alguien que escucha
a todos los americanos
no solamente a la gente que tiene dinero
o que se mira de una manera él escucha a
todos yo siento que yo como latina hija
de inmigrantes yo bailé no importa mi
comunidad en california y otros estados
ambos candidatos están cortejando
fuertemente el voto latino decisivo en
los comicios del 3 de noviembre ya que
este año los hispanos representan la
primera minoría étnica en el país con 32
millones de votantes elegibles